Ось так виглядав Берлін на річницю повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Українці пройшли ходою центром міста, щоб висловити свій протест
проти російської агресії і масових вбивств мирних мешканців України.
Цю та десятки інших видовищних акцій за останній рік у німецькій столиці
влаштувала громадська організація Vitsche.
Днем народження організації, що об’єднала українську громаду в Берліні,
активісти вважають 30 січня минулого року -
саме цього дня відбулася перша акція під назвою "Війна не має кордонів".
Тоді вони вимагали ввести ембарго на енергоносії з Росії
і припинити економічну та будь-яку іншу співпрацю з РФ.
Це було дуже цікаво. Всі піднялися з цього S-Bahn,
який ще працював тоді. Всі люди, не знайомі один з одним,
зібралися, щоб робити віче. Тобто дуже горизонтальним способом.
Майже ніхто нікого не знав до цього.
Це було дуже сильно, бо зібрані були за спільною ціллю
- це підтримка України і допомога всіма нашими можливими ресурсами.
За рік існування Vitsche трансформувалася.
Тепер це зареєстрована громадська організація зі своєю структурою.
Якщо до повномасштабного вторгнення РФ метою зібрань були демонстрації,
культурні заходи та лекції з історії України,
то після - пріоритетом стали організація масових демонстрацій
та збір гуманітарної допомоги.
Коли ти приходиш на акцію, дуже важливо розуміти, що зараз час говорити про суб’єктність України.
Цього не було, не було дуже довго. Цього не було на Паризькій конференції,
цього не було в 2014 році, в 1991 році…
Коли люди приходили і хотіли робити проєкти,
Україну поміщали просто у проєкт Osteuropa, не надаючи суб'єктність.
Нарешті наш голос час від часу чують.
І це дуже важливо, якщо ми хочемо жити в цьому світі горизонтальному, тобто світі рівності.
"Віче" і надалі залишається волонтерською організацією.
Основна команда налічує близько 19 людей,
але до роботи організації долучається і громада, а це понад 200 людей.
Організація запам'яталася яскравими акціями,
деякі з них виглядали як справжній перформанс.
Я пам’ятаю, як один німецький фотограф, який приходив нас фотографувати,
потім поїхав в Україну, фотографував моїх знайомих, друзів,
і він їм розповідав, що Боже, ми всі в захваті, які українці… яка в них велика уява.
На 5 серпня ми виставляли 57 голів Леніна в сміттєвих пакетах,
а на фоні грала всі дев’ять годин лекція Рафала Лемкіна про радянський геноцид проти українців,
яку він виголосив у 1953 році.
Попри те, що демонстранти отримують підтримку з боку місцевої влади,
організовувати демонстрації та акції для українців не так просто.
Складнощів багато, які пов'язані з, мабуть, нерозумінням суб'єктності чи чогось.
Найбільший біль для нас це 8-9 травня,
коли через кому заборонили український та російський прапор.
Коли я мала браслет синьо-жовтого кольору, я проходила повз радянський меморіал.
Мене зупинила поліція і сказала: "Ви в українській символіці, ви маєте це зняти."
Браслет! А через дорогу чоловіки з прапором ДНР на футболці, георгіївські стрічки.
Я кажу: "Але ж там порушення, ви бачите, а він: "Я за це не відповідаю".
А коли підходиш туди, вони кажуть: "Георгіївська стрічка під це не підпадає"...
Теж коли ми бойкотували приїзд Дєда Мороза з Росії до російського дому.
Коли ми реєстрували акцію, я пам’ятаю, як нас дуже далеко відпускали.
Три рази нас переміщали під час цієї акції, і останнє - це взагалі казали: "А станьте отак за будинком".
Утім, попри перепони, Vitsche продовжує організовувати акції в німецькій столиці,
реагуючи на потреби України у війні.
Один з потужних меседжів останніх місяців
- це заклики до німецького уряду надати необхідні Україні німецькі танки Leopard 2.
Free the Leopards - це був просто величезний рух.
У цьому випадку дуже чітко видно, що ти
- крапля в океані, але океан разом - це хвиля змін.
Якби наші захисники і захисниці день і ніч не клали життя,
те, що ми можемо досягти з іншими організаціями не тільки в Німеччині,
а по всьому світу, було б просто нереально.
Будь-яка наша невеличка, маленька, велика перемога
- це все завдяки їм. Тому що люди дізналися умовно про цей архетип героїв Крут.
І він триває, він росте, і ми всі здобуваємо від нього.